good morning Millennials we are here
today with blonde John the toast the
creator of good morning Millennials
good morning Millennials you wish we
named the show good morning on ales no I
just wish that I got credit for what I
have started oh my god they always give
you credit we always have you around it
the story goes we came up with so many
names for this show and one of them was
good morning Lenny else and like a lot
of people were really into it and we
told Ben to get his feedback and he said
good morning it sounds like if an alien
landed on earth and was trying to fit in
with the kids so we are the morning
toast we are here for such a fun special
episode with buns on the toes I'm very
excited I'm very thank you very much for
having me and Claude thank you so much
for not being here allowing me to be
here we're so excited we have so many
great questions for you which of course
we will get to after we hit you with the
fast five stories but before we begin we
have so many exciting housekeeping
announcements first of all we launched
camp toes presale yesterday we are so
money excited it's gonna be lit as hell
general public tickets go live today at
noon so after the show the tickets will
be in the link in our Instagram bio and
our Facebook page anywhere you can find
us you will find the tickets you guys
it's gonna be so much fun Ben we were
talking in the car cuz Claudia said that
you're not coming but I assumed you guys
were coming unfortunately I won't be
there
that's actually the extra Premium
Package do they know my venmo Benjamin -
software I'm hosting a separate event
that you can come directly to dinner
it's a dinner no I think it's more of a
an all-girls camp like like oh yeah I'm
going on in all-girls camp it's a
getaway weekend like just for the girls
no like I just like want you guys like
have your fun
do your thing without a man they're just
well they're like Rhett reckon the time
there will be a man there in his name is
Theo no Theo's gonna be at my brush no
that's why you should come with the Oh
like so you can be on Theo Patrol deal
would have the greatest time at camp
toast I'll come if it is what the people
want okay
the people really want me to come out
come okay that's good to know we have a
private cam to a Facebook group for all
the people who will be in attendance and
that's where we will pull them and we'll
find out if you should does everybody
know like what camp toast is and what
they're getting themselves into well so
that's what's funny is I feel like
either you went to camp and you know
exactly what campus or you're like what
the hell this is a cult we're all going
up to the woods together to be murdered
and I just want you to know that campus
it's not that it's gonna be so fun it's
out of our old campgrounds beautiful
spacious palatial greenery and it's
gonna be a camp weekend we're gonna have
color where we're gonna have like
campfires bonfires talent shows the
toast live from the rec hall so you'll
be getting the tow served to you
directly every morning there will be
drinks it's like camp
fun so like sports ropes course
waterfront canoes swimming there's two
pools and it's all of that but like with
fellow toasters who we just all have the
same things in common and with alcoholic
beverages and it truly sounds like my
dream come true it sounds incredible
we're making what an infomercial we're
making our own dreams happiness can see
I don't know but I think I could I could
[ __ ] with QVC totally you just you just
sold like 10,000 in product I just sold
my 30 seconds and it's gonna be so much
sell once you get there everything is
included food alcohol lodging your bed
all you have to bring is your positive
attitude betting and like whatever the
hell you want to wear which could be
whatever mm-hmm
the positive attitude piece like I feel
like it might be tough like it's like I
feel like the culture surrounding the
toast is like like Treach like do you
feel that way like I feel like everyone
is just gonna have like a sigh when they
get that like [ __ ] it's hot like it's
not like you're it's September in the
plans actually full time of year that's
true it's gonna be so lovely and
beautiful I'm coming as buddy and I are
like the Queen's of Treach and it's not
gonna be Treach we will like we wouldn't
put on something that stretch for you
guys like we love you too much
you're coming I'm coming isold I'm there
I'm sold
okay if you haven't got your tickets yet
if you're paid remember they're
available to now on the patreon page if
you're not a peach remember 12 o'clock
noon Eastern Time
tickets are available we'll see you in
the Poconos I'm I can't [ __ ] wait I
just realized that I'm like looking
there
there's nothing really there I should be
looking there right well when you're
talking to the people look there when
you're talking to me look at me when
you're talking to the lamppost look at
the lamp cool
okay so are you ready to get into the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up need a bite out of
your morning toast some really juicy
stories stories well-rounded per usual
because we're just done talking about
trash right except no trash a little bit
of trash I mean it's all trash I mean
this is a morning toast Arthur Oh
honestly any morning news is trash like
evening news like that there's one thing
per day like in general like all news in
my opinion it's good trash though it's
like I want to talk about it yeah I'm
saying like it's not like it's not like
we like won a war it's like no ex person
dated ex person which I want to hear and
I want to talk about well speaking of
person dating person Kris Jenner is
fueling rumors that she is engaged to
Corey gamble you guys I'm shook James
Corden knows the best way to get his gut
guests to talk is to play a game of
spill your guts or fill your guts on
CBS's the Late Late Show just ask Chloe
Kim and Kendall Jenner
so when Kris appeared on Tuesday's
episode to promote Keeping Up with the
Kardashians he dedicated a segment to
grilling his guests over some gross grub
James gave Chris a choice answer his
questions or even the thousand-year-old
egg blood headcheese a bull penis a cow
tongue crickets deep fried brother hot
sauce or a sardine smoothie I feel like
you would eat some of those things can
you what just happened though yeah James
Corden plays a games
yeah bets or failure yes so if he asks
you a question and if you don't want to
answer it you have to eat one of these
things so he asked her why haven't you
done well she asked him why haven't you
done a carpool karaoke with Kanye West
yet great question he said I can answer
this easily this is a great question for
me we've tried he's canceled twice maybe
even three times a day
he canceled once as I was turning a
quarter to his house I was in the car
and by the time the call finished I was
outside his house and they were like
he's not in the zone for it right now
we'll do it another time he did send me
a lovely gift he sent me these
incredible flowers in a cube which I'd
never seen before and he sent me a pair
of Yeezys people were like whoa they're
so expensive and I was like yeah they
cost my show forty five thousand dollars
but we love him he's my dream he's not--
he knows that he's my absolute dream
okay then I was thinking that like
there's no
that he wouldn't have Kanye on no I'm
sure he would love to but that's like so
kinase personality unless you catch him
on like a really good day and it seems
as though he has yet to do that next
James Corden asked Kris Jenner you're
the executive producer keeping up if you
had to cut one of your daughters from
the show who would it be and why did she
answer no she took this way did we
answer yeah who would you cut Courtney
because she's the least interesting to
look at I mean she just leads the least
interesting TV life currently so it
would have to be Courtney but you can't
really cut Courtney she's a founding
member of this of this crew that's true
I don't know I find Kendall's super like
unimportant like she's she doesn't
really do anything I agree and we were
saying this last week on the show but
then I also said this week you have you
take about two weeks episode I did I did
not okay
this week's episode was really telling
and Courtney was a pain in the ass that
stuff I think kendall like just did
something that made me think of her so
differently like she was just so
professional and like a good sister and
so for that like she gets a pass but you
had some thoughts on Courtney and Eunice
that you wanted to share with the group
yeah I mean I just didn't know if if
everybody was team Courtney everybody
was team Eunice I am certainly team
Courtney and just in case anybody thinks
that his little getaway was a boy's trip
it certainly was not right that's it I
just wanted to stand for Courtney oh
yeah no I stand for Courtney in the
Battle of Courtney versus battle
Courtney were sisters no I Sam and
sisters but also it's very tough the
show has been on for how many years okay
so at some point in your life of reality
TV your life changes like she should
really have a her own show where it's
like her family if she wants to just not
be going out and doing the same things
that the rest of their costumes are
doing like she should have like a very
don't be tardy type of show like can
Rizzoli Courtney's so boring Kim Zolciak
is a firecracker but I'm I think Kim
Zolciak is a firecracker because it's
her own show no I don't think what
Courtney needs is her own child honestly
this is what Courtney
because left in the dust like a few
years ago and now the dust has settled
and she realized like she's still in it
mm-hmm she when she was with Scott there
was a moment where like he was buying
houses and flipping them and she was
obsessed with interior design and they
could have been like an upscale chip and
Jo told me they wanted to like Chris
wanted to produce that show and Kourtney
didn't want to do it like if she had
done that she would have had like a
whole home decor career separate from
her sisters and she could have like made
her own schedule and nice and they would
have been like an upscale version cuz
like it would have been like luxury
homes and luxury cars like luxury decor
and it would have been so interesting
that she didn't want to do it she didn't
want to do the work no she probably saw
it as legitimizing a career for Scott
which I don't think she wanted to do
that what career does he have keeping up
he's not no no no I know but I'm saying
like like another career but like the
more of a career that he has like the
less she has to like take care of him
and pay him in child support so it's a
win-win I I agree that it would have
been a win-win I'm just saying that
that's why I think that maybe she didn't
do it so what I shut up Chad was didn't
want to work with Scott yeah sad so yeah
justice for for Kourtney did we still do
trust this we still do just has been
enough reporting justice for Kourtney
with unions justice for the rest of them
for Kourtney okay we're going against
Kourtney against Kourtney anyways Jordan
ask Kris if her and Corey gamble are
engaged and she said she's not gonna
answer and then the camera cut to Corey
gamble and he was smiling from ear to
ear what do you think honestly I'm
weirdly so here for them like I'm just
so happy for her like whatever brings
her joy in this life I've heard so many
good things about her her people have
met her that I just want her to be happy
she's been through so much didn't they
break up at a point yes they did and
then they got back together very quietly
also which I appreciate because you're
not taking me on this roller coaster of
your relationship I have my own problem
do you think that they just broke up so
that he would like kind of fall out of
the picture a little bit and then they
date on the side or you think it was a
real breakup I think was probably a real
breakup just trying to figure out like
what they're gonna do with the rest of
their lives me but I figured it out and
it's gonna be marriage I'm a fan of his
like I remember liking him on the show I
think that he's just like a nice guy
yeah I like she needs a nice guy she
could use some like positivity in her
life like where she goes home and she
talked about
like the nice day that he had and like
not drama some regular some regular fat
stuff exactly and I feel like he also is
so like sweet our kids and gives them
really good advice and it's just always
finding a way to be helpful even though
they have people to do everything for
them like he really steps up to the
plate he could sit back and be like oh
I'll have a security guard come to your
house and check on your alarm but he
goes and does it himself yeah he's a
doer he's a doer I'm here for it I'm
here for him tonight honestly hope
they're engaged me too I'm like I would
love a Christian or TV wedding like it
should be about Chris for a second
totally the unsung hero the unsung hero
whose great Kardashian what a good
question I like them all for different
for different reasons I think that Kylie
is incredibly impressive currently it
has to be Kim yeah Kim is Kim is the
waters without came there I know there's
there's nothing uh it is certainly not
Chloe she's so damn annoying to me okay
I don't know I'm just not into like the
rebranding yourself as a fitness guru
type of thing okay I liked like larger
Courtney I larger sorry like I thought
that she was just like more fun and
different like she just went down the
path of like what everybody else is
doing
I like an outlier I mean I feel like she
seems happier now and like that's what's
most important but I guess it's less
entertaining for you and I'm sorry about
that it's less entertaining for me I
understand like this is the show is not
about their happiness like we're
watching it for entertainment
I don't think about Tristan Thompson
you're a big sports guy is he talented
players no he sucks he used to be great
he'd be great I'm sorry I can't believe
I even said that he used to be so decent
okay like me almost calling Tristan
Thompson great was such a bad call he
was never great he was always like a
role player like he fit his job okay he
like deserved to be in the NBA he
deserved to make money like a real NBA
player for sure okay he is currently
complete flaming garbage like there is
there is nothing to him whatsoever but
it seems like the Kardashians like to go
after that NBA player like Kris
Humphries was super similar
Curren February's was a benchwarmer no
no Kris Humphries and Tristan Thompson
are very similar NBA players now always
always always yes they're always middle
of the pack they start
I think play like 2025 minutes each get
like ten points ten rebounds just do
their job what did the same guy what
about Lamar Lamar was a little better he
again was not a star the only star the
Kardashians have dated is Blake Griffin
he's the only star and that turned out
really well did you guys talk about that
well I just like like his child support
no we actually didn't because so can i
thoughts on that feel like that
relationship was a little fake and I
just don't like to give it credence by
talking about it but please sure tell me
about it Blake Griffin is paying more
monthly child support then NBA players
are getting salaries I don't know if
that made sense then other and other NBA
players Isiah Thomas not to make this
all that sports no I heard about Isiah
Thomas no I haven't and you know this is
the kind of expertise we need on the
show because so many times we've asked
into the void is Tristan Thompson good
at basketball and we can't get a
straight answer so I really appreciate
that there's a man named Isaiah Thomas
whose career sadly over the last two
years has gone downhill he was
incredible making 30 million a year like
some tragic things to happen in his life
he's now making three million bucks a
year okay still nothing
Blake Griffin's baby mama is making
three million dollars a year three and a
half million dollars a year okay I think
I think I messed that up in the
beginning I know I said that it was
three million dollars a month she's
making $300,000 a month just for being a
mom just for being a mom I'm saying like
a job that's it's a lot of money that is
that is so crazy but I guess Blake
Griffin is just like that rich mountain
okay another one for you James Harden
where does he fall incredible okay the
best I completely forgot about that
dated Chloe yeah yeah he's like the
third best player in the NBA
I was actually also really here for them
cuz he stayed with her like through all
the lamar's remember when he was in the
hospital he's really nice
he seems nice he is I'm sorry I'm acting
like I think about what I think he's
nice what about miles
Austin the bat the baseball player that
Kim dated is it baseball er
I think it's football Miles Austin
really X cowboy somebody can hat sir
Dallas yeah he was good and Reggie Bush
by the way Reggie great at the time and
he won the Super Bowl when he was dating
Kim yeah I mean they kill all their cars
for sure but that's just also the
trajection of athletes like you're great
and then your lesson no because it's not
long enough period of time like it's
really incredible it happens they all
just that's it okay but are you here for
Chloe interested in like knowing the two
of them separately ish being a really
close friend of Tristan I think the
Chloe's really good for him I agree but
it's just good for Chloe yeah I think
that as long as he doesn't [ __ ] up again
I think that and like this may be an
unpopular opinion and I think that it's
across all sports in general not just
men not just women when you datin
athletes it's they're weird it's very
tough you're away from each other for
six seven months out of the year there's
a lot of pressures going on and I think
there's nothing worse in the whole world
than cheating but you can't exactly act
surprised when a pro athlete in any
sport cheats on someone like it's kind
of like it happens way too often do you
think all athletes cheap no but I think
90% of athletes okay because it's it's
just it is what it is it when it's too
easy you're away from your husband or
wife all the time you make so much money
and if people throwing themselves at you
and odds are if you met your husband or
wife while you were this famous then
you're gonna cheat if that makes sense
the people that like that came people
that came up with them like LeBron has
never cheated on his wife that's
confirmed confirmed and it's because
they're high school sweethearts it's
very different like when you actually
love each other and grew up pre Fame I
don't think you cheat but odds are you
got married
post Fame gone and cheat okay does that
make sense yeah thank you for all of
your insights sometimes I jumble my
words a bit this is doing a great job
pickle yeah natural ok next story is
exciting and something that we reported
on the speculatively but now it's
confirmed that Denise Richards is
joining the Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills my how the
have fallen I'm of two minds on this cuz
I actually liked nice Richards and I'm
curious to see what she's up to now and
we read these articles that Charlie
Sheen his lap is down to his last ten
million dollars so like her child
support funds are running out well he
was up he had like 200 million yeah
thank you like literally every time he
spends a dollar Starbucks so she has
gotten a job over at Bravo and on the
one hand I'm not here for traditional
celebrities becoming Real Housewives
because like it just bothers me I can't
explain it I also read a rumor that Tori
Spelling was joining the cast too and
like that I'm not here for that
whatsoever so don't even think about it
but I'm here i-i'll give her a chance
sure sure and you doesn't like oh sorry
can you just give me the three people
like just mean three people are okay
yeah yeah I just I I know the trial I
know the show just sometimes I like I
need the name to know which season it is
yeah or which which County
I actually really like Beverly Hills I
think that there is there's already
enough drama though and she seems like
she's just gonna be like a piece that
like hangs out on the side like the core
drama is Lisa Rinna to read well Lisa
Rinna is out of the drama yeah but to
really kind of came in and my created
the drama like I thought that for sure
well she got to me she had to make a
splash yeah so if Denise Richards comes
in and like is a [ __ ] psychopath then
maybe she can she can make some waves
yeah but if she just like actually has
her her life documented on camera she's
not gonna be that interesting I agree
well she's really pretty so that's that
works in her favor
I don't it's not but pretty has never
really dictated how well you've done on
the show no but I personally enjoy
watching good-looking people Oh fine
short you know all of a sudden like
you're more interesting which is a
terrible thing to say also we will it be
recapping Real Housewives of New York in
a little bit but not much happened it
was more of a filler episode to get us
from Carta Hanyu back to New York I did
watch Carter hanya though the whole
thing so I know that you guys were in
Colombia wild card to Hannah was
down literally yeah it's also crazy that
the entire boat incident was because the
[ __ ] captain left the anchor dragging
while they're going 60 miles an hour
dragging I think it fell because it was
like such chaos its fell down I don't
think the the captain left the anchor
down it's still out you don't have like
a notification that the anchor fell like
what are they doing on some rinky-dink
boat I don't think anchors can just fall
I mean I think that they can in like a
1930s boat like a 28 boat you don't get
a notification anchor dropped warning it
might have been a 1930s boat great and
Bravo needs to spend a little more
[ __ ] money on boats when they send
their cast to another path to another
island in Colombia and is there any way
what's up Tinsley it was her her idea
was the boat yeah like are we really
expected to believe that she set up that
boat not Bravo like why would do you
know what I know I agree logistically so
this is what Darren said she was here
last week she's Annie's assistant she
said that like the women will like
choose the trip so Tinsley did choose
Colombia I'm sure she had a hand in
choosing itinerary cuz she's been there
a lot of times before and then Bravo
orchestrates it so no Tinsley did not
book that specific boat but was what was
most annoying about Tinsley is like she
was taking also personally that she
couldn't even admit that she put them in
such danger like I don't think was tense
Lee's fault whatsoever that they were on
that and was a little bit her fault she
chose Columbia but but I'm saying you
can't no I can't blame someone for going
to a country no they weren't and they
didn't blame her but what was
frustrating is they are literally
throwing off up off the side of the boat
[ __ ] in their pants and tensley's
they're saying this is not a big deal
this happens all the time and but they
all had her attitude they wouldn't have
been [ __ ] their pants they would
have been throwing up because it's the
sea like I was the last time I was on a
boat I puked
I think I'm boats on a boat with you I
puked oh god yeah I [ __ ] swam in it
or we wanted to curse cuz I just be the
person out the wazoo person out the
wazoo
do they know that story I actually
think they know the story this was the
same day that in tune with what's
necessary was born it was a very
treacherous day yes we went to Nantucket
and Jews and Nantucket is a crazy thing
we were the only Jews there it's not a
thing it's not a thing we rented a boat
for the day it was just me Jackie and
Claudia the original trio we rented a
boat went out to sea for whatever reason
I thought that I could captain a boat
actually I think I did a pretty good job
but it was kind of a small boat I didn't
know at the time that I like was prone
to seasickness because I hadn't been on
a boat in a while so it wasn't me I was
hungover oh you were hungover this so
between like just the boat moving
beneath me my hangover I was throwing up
off the side while Ben was on the other
side of the boat like talking to some
people like because everyone was like at
this private island I answered you and
we were swimming you were swimming on
one side I was throwing up on the other
side and then you came around to like
Simon up and you swam in my puke yeah it
was so diluted by then that he didn't
realize until I told you I should have
never told you no you should have never
told me ignorant is less totally good
times yeah good times
we should go back there I mean I imagine
what you're swimming in in that ocean
anyway right like it well puke
everything do bell's puke I weird I
don't know I don't know anyways next up
we have some tech news for you and it's
honestly like very important to me
personally because I do feel so paranoid
of technology sometimes but Apple says
that your iPhone isn't eavesdropping on
you liars
Tech users have long question whether
mobile devices and smart speakers
eavesdrop on their private conversations
Apple answered that question today with
a resounding no in a letter to federal
lawmakers the tech giant insisted that
iPhones do not listen to what users are
saying and said third-party app
developers don't have access to audio
data quote iPhone doesn't listen to
consumers except to recognize the clear
unambiguous audio trigger hey Siri huh I
hate her said a Timothy Powderly Apple's
director a federal government affairs
wrote in the letter which was obtained
by CNN the customer is not our product
and our business model does not depend
on collecting vast amounts of personally
identifiable information to enrich
targeted
profiles marketed to advertisers I think
they're asking the wrong person
they should be asking Alexa I don't know
somebody is listening because like when
we have just like a casual conversation
like I don't know this morning I had
Cheerios in like 30 minutes I'll go on
Facebook and there'll be an ad forty
Rios and I never searched Cheerios and
that's how I know somebody's listening
to me no I'm a friends were in the car
together and they were talking about
someone like random someone so random
that they don't even like look at an
Instagram and they open their Instagram
and her picture was the first one to
come up like that's weird
those I believe are coincidences though
how many citizen how many coincidences a
pattern make totally but you all are
friends of friends and like the like
that girl is like so close to you no I
got it was a random no like a couple of
degrees of separation I guess she's a
random girl but she's not random the
same way that the way the Facebook
creates suggested friends is because six
of your close friends are friends with
her but you're not friends with her so
she pops up so then when you were
talking about that one friend that
you've never met you're like oh my god
like now like it makes sense that one I
don't agree with the Cheerios thing even
though there was a bad example it's
spooky do you know what I mean like
you're on Facebook and then you get like
an ad yeah that's something you were
talking about yeah not a person no as
long as it's something that you're
talking about that's weird but once you
start something on your computer like
that data was embedded and you will keep
getting the same top suggestion from
revolve until you buy it and even after
you buy it yep ritz-carlton I'm not
booking a vacation anymore one time one
time but honestly Alexa does listen yeah
that's why I put her on me I'm [ __ ]
done what are you I put her on me when
I'm like I don't know having government
sensitive conversations but like I like
her because when I'm sitting to him a
make up I don't have to go to my iPad to
put on music I'm like Alexa play Kelly
Clarkson and she starts with the worst
songs
Alexa next another terrible song that
I'm Alexa next and there's a terrible
remix of a terrible song like where is
my god Kelly Clarkson Alexa needs to get
better taste in music because like when
you ask her to play an artist she's
constantly [ __ ] up I asked you to
play the beauty in the Beast soundtrack
the other day and she was every song was
from the score not this lyrical song
[ __ ] [ __ ] get it together it's not
cool
I was never a big Alexi user Claudia is
the queen of Alexa we have one in our
bathroom we have one in our living room
that's about it
but I I I don't know I see the value
like Alexa do acts but like I also would
just prefer to go on Spotify and play my
own song Alexa just doesn't provide
anything to me that I can't get on my
own if I'm just a little bit less lazy
tiny bit less lazy tiny bit less yeah
I'll be like Alexa what time is it I can
also just fine that up also what's
stopping Apple from doing Alexa play
Kelly Clarkson Siri played Harry Carson
yeah I don't know I'm sure that they
could do it hey Siri oh you're asleep
anyways so you can feel a little bit
safer with your Apple phones but I don't
know I just wouldn't trust that person
what are they app what are the cameras
what about laptop cameras that's what
I'm saying and like I don't want to get
into like conspiracy theories yeah but
like I don't know I just feel like they
have like a trillion people watching
porn like not to talk about porn but
like that's like one one thing that like
people are obviously quite nervous about
right in terms of cameras for sure but
here's the thing about that like first
of all watching porn is aren't illegal
so if the government has all this
footage of people watching porn like
what are they gonna do send it to
everyone's wife like it's not a big deal
like I agree it's just it's just
unnerving and like if Apple released
like either a clip or like some like
little shutter they can might go over
the screen so that I don't have to like
take take like a piece of tape when I'm
feeling nervous you know you gotta you
gotta bring your own tape you know IOT
you guys you IOT okay this next series
really crazy and uber tried to warn us
you guys but you ignored the crisis and
now New York City has just capped the
number of over and lift vehicles in the
city and this is a disaster a New York
just became the first US city to cap the
number of ride-sharing vehicles and
require uber lyft and other companies to
pay drivers a minimum rate well that
part's nice regulatory changes in New
York City
Uber's largest US market could provide a
model for other cities either terrain in
ride-sharing firms that have increased
congestion even as they revolutionize
transportation and they have the package
of bills approved Wednesday
New York City Council calls for among
other things a one-year freeze on new
for hire vehicle licenses as a city
explores ways of reducing traffic
congestion it also ensures that
rideshare drivers earn at least seven
$17.22 per hour supporters of the law
including Mayor Bill de Blasio said it
will ease gridlock and improved wages
but critics said will make it harder and
more expensive to get around and it will
this is a horrible horrible thing you
guys this is not are you done reading no
I'll jump in this vice president said
these sweeping cuts to transportation
will bring New Yorkers back to an era of
struggling to get a ride oh we're taking
off for communities of color and in the
outer boroughs we will never stop
working to ensure New Yorkers have
access to reliable and affordable
transportation in every borough
I completely agree this is a smokescreen
what Bill de Blasio has done and I am
I'm about to tear into him Tarrington
smokescreen the reason why the city has
so much [ __ ] congestion is because
there are 10 trillion construction
projects that never end every single
Street has massive construction I don't
know if it was Bloomberg or de Blasio
whoever put in huge bus lanes that take
up half of Madison Avenue that is why
there is congestion no left the bike
lanes no but that was Bloomberg know
what left turns no right turns okay go
straight you can't go back you can't go
anywhere it has nothing to do with the
amount of cars it has to do with what is
going on in our city which is
construction homeless which is
construction which is made slower by
government regulation maybe if you
loosened up construction will be built
faster and we could clear these roads
the bike lanes well think about the bike
lane says if I ever rode a bike in the
city like I'd be so scared to use those
bike lanes like and there's many times I
open up my cab door into those bike
lanes like just oh me sorry Claudia she
literally blindfolds herself and just
swings it open she's never hit anyone
thank God but it's everything the bus
lanes he's got it down to three lanes we
have more cars than ever because like
the we're moving into the future and the
future is cars as it was in the 1900s
and it's here's here's a perfect example
of what's wrong with the city
you're on 34th Street trying to go down
Park Avenue you can't make a left onto
Park you have to make a right onto Park
Oh up to 35th Syd and I traffic then
make the left to go up to 30th to go
down 2-0 down Park Avenue yep so you are
creating so much more traffic by not
letting people just go the way they need
to go because now they're sitting on
other streets where they don't need to
be causing more traffic I can't we need
a traffic mayor like a person yes just
dedicated to traffic who I don't know
how you become an expert in traffic laws
and traffic patterns but that's what we
need there's one problem that we did not
mention I don't know if you're gonna say
I want to say it on three I wish you
knew it I'm gonna say wait wait there no
there is what yes de Blasio was the king
of problems but there is a smaller man
that is the problem what no one two
three traffic cops
traffic cops do nothing I prefer just to
pay them to sit at home because us
paying them to stand there and oh come
come yeah it's [ __ ] green light
that's why I'm supposed to go right stop
shut up red white the same way that you
just said that in the 1900s cars were a
thing yeah when they invented the
traffic light that was so that people
didn't need to tell us when to stop and
go now and like if there's a big no left
turn sign why is that traffic cop
telling me to make a left turn if you
want to if we're able to make a left
turns let's remove the sign like what is
she doing there I don't know every
single time there's a traffic cop there
is problems I like I I feel so badly for
traffic cops because they're really just
doing their job you think they want to
be yelled at and one time like I wanted
to scream and I try the cops so badly
but I'm just like such a wimp I did not
but I saw someone else do it at that
moment and he was so [ __ ] nasty to
the traffic cop him and I felt terrible
and now I had like a new sympathy for
traffic cops you know how much [ __ ] they
take a ton of [ __ ] but just for anybody
that drives in the city a quick hack
traffic cops have no power I will make a
left they don't have a ticket book do
whatever the hell you want they have no
power they can't take it you they can't
do anything and if you really want to
make that left make that left so this is
terrible for people who ride
but also people who work for uber
because now they're talking they're not
gonna be allowing new drivers and if you
ever like talk to your driver like
there's they're so interesting and
they're doing like so much more than
just super like they're in night school
and they drive during the day to pay for
school like there's ubermann evil both
the people that work for uber and the
people that are consumers of uber and
this is a terrible terrible terrible
terrible terrible terrible thing it's
the king of side hustle uber is just
like like people just do it to make a
little extra cash it's important like
it's important to supplement like
supplement incomes like so that you
don't have to work like three three
crazy jobs you can just get in your car
and that can be your second job it helps
so many people get around and then there
also is like uber pool via which are
also amazing and to help congestion and
if you want to help congestion you
should be not taking away Hueber
encouraging people to use uber pools so
maybe like the government can give them
some sort of grant to make a where pools
less expensive and more and incentivize
people to use uber pool it's the the
answer isn't to take away Hueber like
that is just not it's just that's
totally too much government regulation
who the [ __ ] are you totally and if you
want to focus on increasing the salaries
of uber drivers maybe start with
Columbia where I just was because two
things about that number one uber is so
incredible that I was able to get an
uber in under four minutes in the
mountains of Bogota that is incredible
like normally I would have been [ __ ]
stranded there or I would have had to
deal with a language barrier like I
don't speak Spanish
he would have reamed me out for
everything I had the uber was was
regulated on my credit card the same way
and those drivers that were paid nothing
so if you want to deal with instead of
dealing with an $18 minimum salary for
uber drivers here who are all just
trying to make extra money the people in
Bogota who are making it it's like their
main life that are making $4 going 45
miles we should start there I totally
agree and I feel like part of like mayor
de Blasio did this like help the cabs
because cabs were really set like yellow
cabs are really suffering from uber but
yellow cabs we're suffering because they
too weren't in to move for what's
necessary first of all the prices like
you get in the car and you start at $5
before you even move a foot and second
of all like getting being a cab driver
getting a medallion
to even drive a cab is so expensive it
like it takes years okay and like you
they didn't evolve with the times and
for that reason you got left behind but
not anymore Krista Bosnia is pushing you
to the forefront because he doesn't care
what the people want
it's old news when did medallions come
out 1920
I have no it's a let's say oh it's a
1920 it's a hundred year business did
really well yeah
time to move like move on right like
there is there actually is no need for
New York taxis none well now there is
because you can't get an uber yeah me no
it's better eliminate all the [ __ ]
taxis everything becomes uber then all
of the prices drop and Marin business
they should be talking to us I can't
believe they could make the decision
like just overnight in de Blasio's
living room and now we're all have to
suffer like it's just it's just a front
cuz he doesn't want to admit that he
[ __ ] up the city vote he [ __ ] up the
city and like they I'm saying he wants
to he wants to say oh it's ubers ubers
problem for congestion when really it's
his problem for all of the reasons that
we have laid out this has been your
nightly news if you're not if you don't
live in New York well 1 congratulations
because this rule doesn't apply to you
but to you should start like hurting
your looks coming coming we're just the
first we're the first domino to fall you
guys and it's unfortunate ok
fifth story just another sad business
story Walmart is giving less shelf space
to Twinkies hostess Falls 16% this is
like I this this is kind of a trend that
we've been reporting between like
hostess McDonald's Pillsbury sold off
some of their goods and like I just feel
like in this new organic world that we
live in like hostess this isn't gonna
cut it anymore I'm gonna I'm gonna make
a bold statement as a man that seems
like he would really love a Twinkie or
two I think they taste like [ __ ] there
are such better bad snacks that's the
problem if you were telling me that
Entenmann's was losing shelf space for
those delicious little cookies that are
literally like a drop of heaven that
would concern me a bad like like a bad
product though losing shelf space makes
sense but you're a brand of of Junction
but people love them know they love them
but there are things that they love more
yeah and I guess there
so many more options these days so get
them on Amazon if you really love them
that's fine losing shelf space host this
shouldn't be in Walmart anymore whoa
that's a bold claim the maker of
Twinkies hohos and Ding Dongs reported
disappointing earnings Wednesday sending
its flocks stopped sliding 16 percent 16
percent hostess brands CEO said
Wednesday the company had been hurt in
the second quarter by shrinking shelf
space and lower promotional support from
one large retailer the CEO did not
specify the name of the retailer but an
analyst on a conference call with the
company executives revealed it was
Walmart like maybe change the name grab
me a ding dong like I don't know but
that's like the power of Walmart oh my
god yes this is a little shelf space and
you go down to 16% yes yes we gotta get
in Walmart we need to get to put the
toaster on the shelf in Walmart totally
I don't show hosts on the Shelf where
we're like just being annoying oh yeah
anyways I hope you guys can netiquette
together over there at Hostos it's just
such a an American institution but I
guess just like the taxis you know all
good things must come to an end for
bigger and better things in organic
products and I don't know tastier
Entenmann's did we ever talk about Toys
R Us I know it's old news but now that
we're talking about like old businesses
going out we did not talk about it's
really sad that's sad but see that's
because great your toys on Amazon yeah
but it's nice for a kid to be able to go
into a toy store it doesn't [ __ ]
matter if a kid goes into a Walmart and
sees a hostess like it
it's a hostess it's not like right it's
not like it doesn't pull at the
heartstrings no but you seem torn up
about Toys R Us yeah that you can't take
your son there yeah but think about it
like you have children where do they go
to get toys they can't go and play with
toys and like house yes like whatever
town you're in there's probably like
some boutique toy stores yeah what kind
of what kind of organic toys are they
gonna have there like non-gmo like like
made and like I don't [ __ ] know oh
yeah they're just coming back there's
gonna be worse toys to table there'll be
worse - yeah exactly they're gonna be
worse toys and they're gonna be so
expensive yeah like like a I can't even
imagine because they're all handmade you
know there's those toy stores the
randomly see where like the people who
own the store like me that
or spy hands oh wow do you know what I'm
talking about I went to a toy started
sweetened cuz I got it have you ever
played jacks of course so I was with
Margot Lewin and we're best friends from
camp we used to play jacks we played a
hundred games a day we would walk from
bunk to bunk with our jacks oh my god we
have to have Jack's a camp toast
we would walk from bunk to bunk like
with our Jack's just challenging
everyone until we bought Jack's and by
the way we still had it Jack's is the
best most wholesome most sleep ever the
only part that's hard about planning as
an adult is sitting on the floor is
torturous like not having toys-r-us
means the kids won't play jacks and
they'll just play games on their phone
and we're done ever interacting with
each other I agree and it's very very
sad and their play on the iPad yeah it's
terrible I'd like to quickly apologize
for the amount that I'm clearing my
throat I'm sure that Claudia is oh no I
I've been doing it like once every three
minutes but I know that it bothers
Claudia it bothers Claudia deal with it
sorry where does that come from
if I if I don't take my sur tech early
enough it hasn't hit yet it's a little
bit too early it'll probably like clear
up in like an hour
I really didn't notice and I remember
you cleared her throat like at 3 to 1 on
the live and I was like oh this is gonna
be a fun show I've done the whole time
I'm happy that you didn't maybe I'm just
so focused on myself it's possible it's
possible
quirin actually speaking of now is the
time in the show where we focus on you
and only you because we have so many
viewer questions thank god you're ready
for it I'm ready we have a lot of
questions for you a lot of them are from
your wife and so I feel like this will
be a good place for you guys to sort of
you know air your marital grievances
perhaps sure I heard your voice cleans
up after you all the time why um
she's never home to clean up after me so
I don't really know Shaddai I don't know
what she's talking about you know what's
so crazy it's the last time you came on
the toast with just you and I you did
the podcast once with me you and Claudia
but you know she's there totally you did
the toast just you and I and it was the
two days before your wedding and once
you're back your married man coming up
on 1-year anniversary
yes how has married life changed at your
relationship or your life at all no it's
it's amazing
it's it's really the same yeah a good
way yeah that's what it seems like and I
think that's the most you can hope for
yeah like you it's you just have your
best friend at home like I mean normally
waiting but
she's off gallivanting the world oh
right she but under toy but under under
normal circumstances you get home she's
their hangout you order dinner you watch
a movie like that's like just like a
normal weekday night or like when you
want to go out and like it used to be
that you had like text all your friends
like your friends just they're like you
guys have Theo Theo Theo changed our
lives more than marriage
seriously like Fred the better oh my god
for the better he's he's the greatest
thing that ever happened to us
Theo in case I mean everybody knows that
he's my dog but I just wanted to make
sure people didn't know that he's myself
yeah he's not your actual Sayaka
he's your son but your dog son I guess
technically he is a dog he's a dog and
he has a lot of aunts who love him sons
one that loves that loves him the most
mm-hmm who had a great day with him
mm-hmm a wonderful day
except you sometimes work him too much
why but then he's so sleepy and good for
you I know but like also dying like one
time I took him for a run but that
happened it happened one and I never did
it again it I think I also is a little
he gets so excited that he's running but
he starts running faster than you and
then he over works himself keeping up
Athiya keeping and he needs his own show
his own show
what did someone ask does Claudia really
eat like a five-year-old Brian Kelly
asked this question yes she does
um Brian Kelly has eaten with Claudia
right so he knows she it's like a
five-year-old he's just calling her out
yeah she I will give her credit though
she she's recently expanded her palate
so from the my palate is as wide as it
comes I will eat literally anything what
won't you eat I won't eat anything non
kosher so you wouldn't need like horse
or deer so I'm even gonna correct that I
said I'd eaten non kosher it's like I've
eaten every seafood on planet Earth it's
not something that I I'd like to talk
about but no but I have done it and I've
enjoyed it I would never eat ya I'd
never eaten animal like that that's just
too strange like a horse or like any
kind of weird delicacy like horses are
so not
like why the [ __ ] are you needing a
horse and for all the people that are
like oh cows have feelings they're so
sweet like cows are clearly [ __ ] dumb
and like they were meant to be eaten
every other animal was not meant to be
eaten
don't kill lions don't kill horses don't
kill dolphins I've never heard of anyone
eating a lion I'm sure people did
dolphins mahi-mahi that's not real it's
the same way that like when you go to a
sushi place and you order a California
roll and they say it's crab that well
that's not crab okay but mahi-mahi is
not that something no I promise you it's
not I promise you that it is but that's
fine if you don't want to accept it
what's one thing what's one thing that's
not kosher like it that you wish would
be that you miss the most just like
going to a restaurant ordering a regular
steak like unfortunately kosher
restaurants just have not gotten it
together that like they're allowed to
make food taste good they just like who
looks kosher so like I'll just like
throw it on the grill and won't give a
[ __ ] about like how it tastes so I miss
being able to go to restaurants order
steak you know what I miss cheeseburgers
mussels are [ __ ] delicious and so
healthy seafood in general that's a
great call like shrimp cocktail
delicious yeah lot of work though yeah
but there it's so much work for no
calories like everybody wants to know
why Jesus so [ __ ] fat it's because
everything that we eat that is fattening
like everything that we can't eat all of
your delicacies in the non kosher
non-jewish world are zero calories no I
totally insane like like why is that I
mean I don't know maybe they just want
us to be fat right maybe that's just the
life where it always meant to be that's
it maybe you should stop trying not to
be okay Alexis waters with the tough
questions if the UN Claudia were
stranded in the middle of the ocean and
could only save one who would it be in
my question obviously but like I there
there would never be the oh I can
literally grab with one hand right that
would never happen
Jesus Christ what important question
another one if you had to be stuck on an
island with one sister not Claudia who
would it be oh I think I know yeah we'd
be Margo really she's the least did she
actually I take it back
it would be Olivia that's right only
because the most words
we're soul I have to think about it in
different ways like if I wanted like
just somebody that I don't think we
would ever butt heads Margo
because she's just like quiet and like
for me with me
Annie Margo rarely getting and we don't
we also don't write you and Margaret
kind of in the same boat over there
Olivia though we don't argue but like
we're both opinionated yes but she is
the most resourceful so like if I
couldn't find food
she would find so I thought that's what
you were gonna say Olivia
stuff you all bring different things no
no there is no bad option that's true
can you do your mrs. Doubtfire
impression yeah let me just I think so
pretty much that's gonna be tougher the
podcast listeners but oh yeah that's
what happens
oh yeah Artie T you digi nya Doubtfire
dear that was good
when should I start a morning show where
I'm dressed up as mrs. Doubtfire quite
like the should right
where I just like do it like it's too
creepy what is it like to have to be
married into a family of women with such
strong personalities um I definitely
knew what I was getting into Claudia and
I dated for over four years
pre-engagement it was it was difficult
to adjust like the first six months but
like after that I have a very strong
personality it would be tough if I was
quiet
yeah I'm not quiet so like when they're
talking like I'll interrupt and we do
have some new listeners because someone
asks how did you and Claudia meet to
tell us all this time tell us all this
time we met at a party just like regular
kids not online
she was waiting on line at the bathroom
we tell this story differently so if you
ask Claudia she'll give you a different
version or like the false version of the
story the real version is that she was
waiting on line for the bathroom at a at
a house party I was super super drunk
and I just ran to the very front of the
line
knocked on the
were like really hard and then when the
person who was in the bathroom open the
door I ran away and they were yelling at
Claudia no they were blaming her for
knocking on the door that is that is how
I met Claudia from there she asked a
mutual friend set us out we were set up
we went on a couple of dates she called
me her boyfriend on vine after that we
took a two-week hiatus because I was a
little creeped and then we got back
together and we weren't date sorry we
weren't dating when she called me her
boys I just want to be very clear all
right well he's never broken go she came
home and said that you wanted space
because like you what was what the exact
terms she claimed that it's because I
wanted to go and hook up with girls in
the club you like you think you wanted
saison you're like what do you mean one
space like you walk into the club and
all these girls want to hook up with you
that was the mind it was six seconds and
it was [ __ ] iconic it was iconic but
yeah she was a little nuts but that's
knowing that she's not nuts anymore
and I love her how does it feel though
to be married to a big time coming it's
amazing and like what she's done and
doing is amazing she is people don't
realize it like how unbelievably hard
she works morning tonight like this show
is just one piece of the of the workload
that literally never stops her art and
she does it all for you guys so you
should be thanking her you should be but
she really is it's amazing and she's
she's blossoming before our eyes like
this is only the beginning I totally and
if you haven't caught a show that's okay
because it's calm oh yes
that's true but that wasn't even I was
gonna say like this is the pilot like
what's coming is [ __ ] massive like
Amy Schumer can eat my ass like this is
like she's gonna be huge I totally let
me make one more one more comment on
that she if you have not seen the show
you won't know this but she is the only
female comic that I have seen that is
able to be funny without talking about
her body
aka vagina I feel like female comics
we lean on vagina jokes like the gym
like the female Jim Gaffigan exactly the
clean comic you can bring your butt and
she's really really funny yeah I agree I
never thought of it like that but yeah
all the female female comics that I have
seen and that I like are the dirty
raunchy and I don't want to get in hot
water so if you are a female comic out
there and you're not raunchy I'm sorry
had not been introduced yet all of the
prominent female comics that I know are
raunchy and they're hysterical but it's
just a different brand I totally agree
yes very exciting stuff and I actually
think that stand-up comedy is the
hardest job in the world and so good
watch comedians in cars getting coffee
like they agree it's the hardest job in
the world also and she just like walks
right into it
hey guys maybe an unpopular opinion can
even use cars getting coffee is not
funny well you can Jerry Seinfeld is
like my my idol really yes I'm but that
show it's like it's funny because
Claudia like doesn't watch Seinfeld but
she loves comedians in cars I don't know
why it's like I'm literally watching an
hour of comedians forced jokes when
they're so funny like it's okay to not
be funny in a diner outside of a park
like you're allowed to have a normal
conversation they're just like so first
episodes where they're like just trying
to one-up each other I like the ones
where they just have conversations like
Gaffigan this is good
yes Steve Harvey was good they were just
talking and they're just funny people
that are just funny exactly but like the
people that are I think that you can be
funny I'm sorry I think you can be not
funny
in real life but be an amazing stand-up
comic I think that's what I've learned
from comedians and cars that there are
some people that just they're like so in
their own head they don't yeah I have to
write out their jokes I agree they're
really funny in that way but they're not
just like like me like conversationally
funny you know totally what is your go
to do at karaoke song with Claudia oh we
don't really do duets more do solos like
people don't realize like I can sing as
well do you want to give us a little
something we haven't sung this morning
on the show I don't really know what I
would sing you can sing like Allison's
no remember I showed you my Josh Groban
yes how was that Wendy could do that / -
that was amazing
it was we did karaoke and caicos
continued clearing my throat so [ __ ]
why
like he sang Josh Groban Claudia sing
Celine Dion Margot and I like did some
Taylor Swift basic [ __ ] but it was like
cute whatever and it was just an amazing
night that was really fun mm-hmm okay
I'll try I'll try and give a bar to yeah
when I am down and oh my soul so weary
when troubles come and my heart burdened
be is that the words burdened be but I
am still something in the silence I will
show you the words what are the next but
I'm still in wait here in the silence
till you find and spend awhile with me
you raise me up so I can stand on
mountains you raise me up to walk on
stormy seas
I am strong when I am on your shoulders
it's so good you raised me beautiful
thank you beautiful beautiful it felt
good
I realized that were in studio space and
everybody outside is probably like what
is going on right but we listen to the
air stuff all the time there were drills
in my head yesterday so if anybody wants
to sign me you can email me right
Lincoln biome um someone wants to know
about your keto diet they have an unpaid
Oh for three months and cannot lose any
more weight they're out of 20 pound
weight loss since month two but they're
trying to lose 50 pounds what is your
experience been like with keto what
advice do you have for this person how
many pounds are you down does it I'm
down 25 pounds I want to know if that
person is skinny now like are they
trying to lose 30 pounds I it seems like
their goal weight was 50 pounds like
they like they're able to lose 30 more
I think hypothetically sounded this
question yes okay I think that you just
because so for everybody that doesn't
know and Claudia is gonna kill me cuz
she hates when I talk about it
keto diet is no carbs high fat high fat
people come to think is mayonnaise bacon
meats like yeah those are high fat but
also avocado is like that like I'm sure
that this person is following the
traditional keto diet the same way you
follow traditional Atkins like in the
beginning if you just consume a ton of
meat you're gonna lose weight and at
some point there you have to break
through better you've got you've got to
eat cleaner one and two now that your
energy is so high from Quito you should
probably go to the gym like I think I
think that like at some point I have not
started the exercise part of my journey
just because I eat or like I play
basketball but I don't I don't like
going to the gym I think that at some
point you need to do those you need to
supplement yeah I agree and also like
with all weight loss like a certain
point you plateau and it doesn't mean
you're done losing weight but that you
just have to work a little bit harder
and once you get over the hump it
it's easier again but I think the most
important thing to do right now at this
plateau is just to keep on being so good
because then your body will undeniably
lose weight it's a science like it's
math and if you put it if you put in the
work you're gonna lose the weight it's
just sometimes your body like fights you
want it but eventually it'll give up and
then you show up weight like that it's
also possible that you don't know that
you're consuming carbs and you actually
are well if she lost 20 pounds or
anything seems like she knows what she's
doing no like one common misconception
you can lose 20 pounds by eating a ton
of broccoli that just doesn't mean that
you're on keto no but that's just means
around a low carb a low calorie diet
no-calorie I'm saying the the like - for
your body to be in ketosis you can't
have carbs there are plenty of great
things that have carbs in them yeah so
it's possible that this person has just
been on a low-carb diet I remember when
I was on Atkins back in the day and like
you didn't like this was pre keto and I
didn't understand I told you you could
drink manis every day I understand lose
weight and you like thought I was
psychotic yes I'm sorry you're right I
actually thought about that the other
day
weirdly that I remember you telling me
that I can eat mayonnaise and it was
fine I think you could drink whatever
you want but yeah your body just changes
the way that it processes foods yeah
also if you try and eat a whole like
container of mayonnaise you're never
gonna want to eat it again so that's
also probably something that works with
the diet when would you like to have
kids
um I would I like to have kids like I'd
love to have a kid right now like it
would be amazing but when am I ready to
have kids is a very different question
probably two years minimum Claudia's
career is just as we've already
discussed like just starting to blossom
you have to not go on tour for the nine
months I think they were a little a
little out okay that's there but I can't
wait yeah and just another another lover
to be an aunt to yes another Love Bug
what's your favorite thing about Claudia
so when you said that this was about me
we meant was this is about Claudia okay
okay that'll be my last question where
okay no we can't understand no I love
her I just like thought it was about me
just
it was a little confused my favorite
thing about Claudia is her confidence
and the way that she pushes that
confidence onto others including myself
I was never as confident of a person as
I am today like from the day that I met
her I was only I was confident when I
met her because when I met her I was
much skinnier than this I had just lost
a ton of weight for the third time so
let's see if I can hold it off this time
so like that gives you confidence but
like she like it she just gives you the
power gives anyone the power to be
confident no matter what I totally agree
it's like I I can't explain it like she
gives me the confidence to go get
something for like my mom will drive
outside to drop something off for me
outside of my building and I have the
confidence to walk outside in my robe I
can't explain it like I just don't give
a [ __ ] that anybody's opinions not in a
rude way like I never want to be
disrespectful but she she empowers me
and everybody else to be that type of
person just to be yourself to be
yourself I totally agree that's a really
great answer this is an interesting
question definitely about you do you
when you're in the shower do you let the
excess soap wash your feet or do you go
out of your way to clean your feet I let
the excess soap wash my feet me too
unless I have like a dirty I'm less like
like right now I'm wearing loafers with
no socks so probably when I get home I
will wash my feet cuz a little stanky
but no I don't but but with that
question just because Claudia does this
anybody that takes a bath and doesn't
shower after is [ __ ] disgusting I
agree baths are you sitting in your
filth unless unless you take a bath just
for like we already clean is just for
like the relaxation purpose but whenever
you take a bath like you just have to
rinse off after you have to take a
shower I totally agree Claudia literally
washes her hair in the bath that's not
what about this for you soak you get up
then you shampoo your hair in the shower
yes indeed everybody even know that
another question for you and I'm
actually curious myself what's something
that you're passionate about like a
hobby sports what's on work I well my
Knicks are my number one so basketball
Giants football Yankees baseball I love
golf love golf I love cooking really
good didn't come to New York I was upset
in 2010 that LeBron didn't come to New
York which is why I've hated him ever
since but now I just know that good
players aren't coming to New York like
why it's such a great place to be ready
the money it's not ready yet
like our team isn't ready what needs to
happen there are two things LeBron is at
a point where he can go wherever he
wants for as much money as as much money
as he wants excuse me so he felt that
the Lakers had a better fit for him plus
it's LA plus he got hundred and fifty
million dollars right that helps also
while we love New York it's cold here
yeah like the the weather is is not
ideal for everyone I agree with that so
I think that LeBron I I could have told
you that he was gonna go to LA because
he loved Miami and it's like similar
weather so LeBron or Kobe Kobe oh I hate
LeBron everybody knows that okay I
respect him and I hate hates hates the
wrong word I
he's like the second greatest basketball
player of all time Kobe's the greatest
Michael Jordan's the greatest Michael
Jordan's produce the third okay okay but
Kobe is he's Kobe he's iconic he never
left the Lakers LeBron phenom four
different teams it's a very different
trajectory yeah and like the NBA has
changed there's no longer any loyalty
and I feel like LeBron kind of pioneered
the age of chasing money as opposed to
being loyal to your fan base cool but I
still respect him just in case he's
watching no for sure I think that was a
very fair assessment as someone who
doesn't know much about the subject
except that I loved him in trainwreck
yes
oh great actor create and I'm very
excited for Space Jam to I don't know if
you knew that that was coming your bigs
you guys have a space Space Station's
the the greatest movie of all time
that's me and Michael Jordan is not
exactly a great actor they really should
have done with Shaq oh do you love Shaq
Shaq Shaq is my favorite person on
planet earth transcending basketball
team
we saw Shakti J a few weeks ago funny
thing he's so funny not the best DJ uh
but you know I'm sure with a little
finesse and a little work he'll pull it
out have you seen Kazaam
no what what's that 1996 Shaq is a genie
watch it when you get home okay no
thanks the next movie of the week what's
your biggest pet peeve I probably have
so many it's weird that I can't think of
one yeah Oh
any man that calls me buddy
he's a huge pet peeve okay hey buddy or
like yeah like don't worry about it
buddy like if you call me buddy I know
you're talking down to me and you think
that you're better than me
so stop doing oh my god I have to say
that's [ __ ] hilarious
think about it Yeah right yeah terrible
I remember this one kid fourth grade
this has been a pet peeve forever I was
playing soccer he's like don't worry
about it buddy like I get it you think
you're better at soccer than me because
you're calling me buddy
but like grab a spoon grab a spoon so
how many times in your household does
someone have to grab a spoon
Claudia nice to eat my ass all the time
oh we don't say grab a spoon we just
just get to the point grab like [ __ ] you
eat my ass like all the time this is the
euphemistic term you know that's a PG
term yes uh who's your favorite
housewife Wow who is my favorite
housewife can you name Oh
Kim Zolciak is she a counselor yes well
she not not at the moment but she's
housewife show is just so much better in
my opinion than all of the other shows
they found a way to not have a dumb
drama and still have a really good show
in Atlanta I mean that's our tea shop oh
no sorry don't be tardy oh just a nice
family just a nice family
oh so interesting it's the same reason
why I love chrisley knows best
you love Kristi I've never watched it
it's the greatest show Wow
I used to love that show do you I don't
want you really anymore but we used to
love it speaking of the greatest show do
you love the greatest Roman love I mean
you guys are really [ __ ] annoying
with it and at this point I know every
word of every song by hardly [ __ ] when
I've never played it myself you guys
like the radio yeah like me just like
that song
in your brain regardless of if you want
to or not so I actually a really
personal question for you okay why don't
you watch the toast because I'm at work
so I'm Jackie and I were talking about
this earlier I wish that I had the
liberties of being able to watch the
toast but I go to work I do my work I
leave right when you're not working you
leave when I'm not working I leave and
when I'm always working between 10:30
and 11:30 typically sometimes I do watch
I also feel like I'm to live it yeah
there's nothing really happens on the
show that you need to know about and
like bits in oh god I mean like I do see
Claudia like with a lot of men sometimes
like taking pictures with like the
guests and like wants to be their wives
no no no that's the job whatever that's
the job um are you gonna get the Oh a
sibling um not at this time
not at this time he needs a cousin he
can he can have a cousin when I can
afford to have help
no he needs a cousin like Oh cause it's
yes you need a cousin
I'd love to have another dog in my house
but it's just a lot of work angry I'm
just a loving loving this question from
Ashley do you absolutely love having
Jackie around yes love so fun Jackie I
like especially in the very very
beginnings of my relationship with
Claudia we were best buds no one the
very very beginning we didn't know each
other our box I was at school we just
started eating Claudia
so like sorry a year in yeah when I
graduated
we were raging in the course everything
we sort of baseball games I remember one
time we went to a baseball game it was
me you and Claudia and we had four seats
and you were like told me I'm gonna
invite a friend see if someone's hang
out with and I was like no I'll use the
seat for my purse just because I know we
were unbelievable we were your stoppable
do you call it a three-wheeler I guess
yes third wheel yeah yeah but like but
it didn't feel like that no not at all
we like like best buds so yeah she's the
best I mean like now that she's like
granny Jackie like she's like a little
less fun like when she turns out well
still turn up from time to time and I'm
just loving being a grandma right now
like understand grandma power and
everyone has to grow up at some point
and like especially for women like
there's a lot of pressure to mature yeah
I understand that's a little horse [ __ ]
and you can be both a granny and a fun
granny a Fanny I'm definitely a Fanny
for sure and I'm a Sun Anthes well
you're fun and always treating my
nephews Anita's yeah but like like
brunch fun we gotta get you back to
night fun to club fun it's hard because
like I don't love the club scene in the
city like when we went when we went to
Atlantic City I had I was that's a good
call I was the most fun gal in the group
night New York City nightlife has really
taken a turn for the worst it really has
like you go to the club and you're not
like breaking it down on the dance floor
you're like standing around your table
like bopping your head right yeah but
when we were in Atlantic City we were
breaking it down I literally like we
needed to move the rope to our table so
that I could like have more space to
dance yeah there's none of that in New
York in case there's any prominent New
York City nightlife owners watching like
maybe Eric marks people like house music
people like the occasional rap song and
people like pop people like mute like
people people like songs that they know
the words to like you don't need to use
your DJ set as an opportunity to
introduce us to new music yes and play
under like play to an audience
pretending like they're not on drugs
because too often they play to an
audience that they think is on drugs and
that's why you get literally eight
straight hours of to students tunes
which I understand people would like if
they're on drugs but if you're not on
drugs we like to hear words right so I
claim I'm gonna blame nightlife in the
city for my grandma evolution because
when we leave the city
I'm always popping off in Nashville at
the honky-tonk like cuz there's words
because there's words and there's fun
like here if I want to go out like it's
just like a house music club with no
lyrics or it's like a seedy bar that
smells nice and the few times we've gone
out and had fun nights recently like we
took the town when we went out for the
night before Margo went to Israel when
we went to the globe that was fun that
was so fun it was empty but it was fun
right but all you need a space and some
good music
anyways Bunge thank you so much for
joining us oh that's it do you have it
more that you want to say no I just like
have no conception of time it's been
it's been an hour intended like yard
time flies when you're on the trust I
can't imagine what it's like to watch
the toes yeah me neither
like now it's lunchtime what are you
gonna have for lunch initially an omelet
hmm probably you already have it
omelette today no I didn't eat oh yeah
really skinny probably is a salmon salad
nice some exams and --which every single
day like there's nothing better than a
sandwich there's something better than a
sandwich
I love it - yeah - there's nothing
better meat is better than tuna no I
don't I'm telly meets creeped me out
tope like some kind of bread toasted
turkey toasted lettuce onion pickle man
yes I'd eat it every day my life I could
do a turkey sandwich lettuce tomato
onion how mustard sure spicy how good is
a turkey sandwich very good right or a
turkey wrap even and bread bread is the
best toes yeah it needs to be toasted it
needs to be toasted do you get for watch
Mad Men no hmm okay sorry I think you
might like it actually anyways thank you
all so much for tuning in we'll be back
tomorrow with Heather McMahon I'm so so
excited to talk to her I'm gonna need
all of your questions like she is so
goddamn funny hopefully she'll do the
Britney challenge teach me how to move
like Britney which is to not move at all
and we will see you tomorrow
oh my gosh 20 minutes camp those tickets
go live for everyone
standby on your computer Instagram link
in bio we will see you there cannot wait
nah thanks
you